Dr. Lola Bergman was an accomplished senior
researcher for the SCP Foundation.
Her years of hard work studying anomalies
and dedication to the Foundation had earned
her a Level 3 security clearance, allowing
her to access a bevy of secret information
across the Foundation’s vast network.
As a researcher and scientist, Dr. Bergman
was the naturally inquisitive type.
She wanted to know everything there was to
know about the strange and esoteric universe
around her.
That’s why, when she heard about the file
for SCP – 2000, one of the organization’s
best kept secrets, she was hooked.
The only problem was that just to view the
file, you had to be on the O5 council or have
a special subset of Level 4 clearance known
as 4/2000.
Unfortunately, Dr. Bergman was only a Level
3.
But you know what they say: The forbidden
fruit always tastes the sweetest.
Dr. Bergman had given the Foundation years
of service.
What could the harm be in breaking the rules
and getting a peek behind the curtain just
this once?
Through somewhat deceptive means, Dr. Bergman
managed to get her hands on some 4/2000 clearance
credentials, and decided to access the file
on an encrypted personal device.
They’d never even know.
But as she entered the credentials, she found
herself suddenly looking at an image.
On its face, nothing, an image of a dirt road
in a field, with tiny white text reading “…Remember
us…”
But this was a powerful cognitohazardous image
capable of causing immediate incapacitation.
The next thing she knew, she was laying on
the ground, unconscious.
When she woke up, she was no longer a doctor
at the SCP Foundation.
She was on a street corner, unable to remember
her own name, let alone her history.
All she could do was murmur something about
a secret under Yellowstone National Park…
Dr. Bergman’s years of service had meant
nothing in the end.
SCP – 2000 is an anomalous asset so vital
to not only the Foundation, but the entire
world, that so much as attempting to access
it without the proper clearance leads to immediate
termination.
But what’s really hidden under Yellowstone
National Park?
And why are the Foundation higher-ups so intent
on keeping it a secret, even from most of
their own ranks?
Of course, Yellowstone National Park itself
is no stranger to anomalous activity.
The entire national park is technically an
SCP known as SCP – 1422.
While it has since been neutralized, SCP-1422
caused all members of the SCP Foundation to
have no awareness of Yellowstone National
Park prior to 2007.
But the true nature of SCP – 2000, the secret
hidden under Yellowstone National Park, is
not only stranger than SCP – 1422, but also
– depending on your perspective – either
profoundly relieving or utterly terrifying.
But before you can truly understand the purpose
and gravity of SCP – 2000, or the Deus Ex
Machina, we need to talk about the end of
the world.
In Foundation parlance, K-class scenarios
are events which have drastic implications
on the state of society, normality, or even
life.
The most dangerous and feared of all of these
are XK – Class Scenarios, which are, for
all intents and purposes, the apocalypse.
There are a worrying number of anomalies capable
of bringing about an XK Class scenario if
the Foundation ever dropped the ball on their
protection or containment.
While the Foundation believes that prevention
is always preferable to the cure, what happens
when prevention doesn’t work?
What happens when our worst fears are realized,
and the end truly comes for us all?
The answer is, SCP – 2000 happens.
Simply put, this anomaly is a reset button.
A chance to start over when all life has been
compromised by anomalous activity.
2000 is a giant and mysterious facility beneath
Yellowstone National Park.
The entrance is disguised as a disused park
ranger station, feeding into a facility that
burrows miles down into the earth.
It’s a place that contains incredible anomalous
technologies capable of bringing the world
back to its former glory, even after the worst
happens.
Only a select few personnel are allowed to
work at the facility, keeping its machinery
maintained in case the day comes when we ever
need to use it again.
These personnel are not allowed to come and
go as they please and their memories of 2000
are wiped if they’re reassigned to different
Foundation duties elsewhere.
Why all the secrecy?
SCP – 2000 is the Foundation’s – and
humanity’s – lifeboat, and as such, the
base is well-guarded both from potential human
threats, as well as anomalous activity and
reality warpers.
The surface-level entrance to the base is
surrounded by a number of strategically placed
Scranton Reality Anchors, or SRAs.
These devices, largely constructed of corrosion-resistant
beryllium bronze alloy, keep certain types
of reality-bending anomalies from manifesting
their powers within the vicinity of the base.
However, these are just the tip of the iceberg
when it comes to the state-of-the-art Foundation
technology employed within and around SCP
– 2000.
You probably have a lot of questions, and
that’s understandable: What kind of technology
can possibly reverse an apocalypse?
And what did we mean when we said we may need
to use it “again”?
Well listen up, because this is going to be
a lot to take in.
SCP – 2000 is powered by a Liquid Fluoride
Thorium Reactor, stabilized by five Xyank/Anastasakos
Constant Temporal Sinks, and host to the most
miraculous technology of all: 500,000 Bright/Zartion
Hominid Replicators.
Utilizing geothermal energy from the volcanic
activity in the area, the base could potentially
remain operational forever if Foundation staff
kept up with maintenance.
The grand majority of the space in this huge,
subterranean facility is taken up by building
materials, construction equipment, factory
machinery, agricultural equipment, and computer
database storage.
Why?
Well, let’s explain the processes of the
apocalypse and how it relates to the activities
of SCP – 2000.
In any K-Class or end of the world scenario
that doesn’t destroy SCP – 2000 in the
process, any surviving Foundation member can
enact Procedure CYA-009, while any Foundation
facilities globally can monitor the unfolding
situation.
While SCP – 2000 is waiting for the “all
clear” to do its thing, remaining Foundation
sites set into motion what is known as the
“Ganymede Protocol.”
This involves collecting and preserving materials
which could be useful during the recreation
process.
However, it’s extremely possible that in
a sudden XK class end of the world scenario
there may be no surviving Foundation personnel,
or at least not enough to maintain any kind
of organization.
Thankfully, there are fail safe measures for
such a scenario.
During the periods of extended inaction caused
by an apocalypse that destroys most human
life, SCP – 2000 will gradually, autonomously
relax its security measures.
Any personnel, regardless of clearance, will
be able to activate the next stage of the
process when this occurs.
If such a thing doesn’t happen for an extended
period, the security measures lapse further,
to the point that even the presence of an
animal could activate it.
This would set into motion Procedure Lazarus-01,
humanity’s last hope for survival.
That’s where the 500,000 Bright/Zartion
Hominid Replicators, or BZHRs, come in.
These incredible pieces of anomalous technology
are capable of perfectly cloning the entire
human race from any given period in the last
twenty years, even down to their ages and
memories, thanks to Class-G hallucinogens
and developmental hypnotherapy.
With a warm-up period of five days, these
machines are capable of creating 100,000 viable,
non-anomalous humans per day.
The facility keeps records of all known human
alleles, and is capable of recreating any
lost human genomes or generating as many new
and unique genomes as necessary to repopulate
human civilization.
Which humans the machines generate depends
on the period of time the machine is ordered
to replicate.
It will first reproduce prominent cultural
and political figures, as well as the acting
top brass of the SCP Foundation to coordinate
the recreation effort, of course.
The machine will then recreate…Well, everyone
else.
You’re probably wondering: If the world
outside SCP – 2000 has been destroyed then
what good is creating all these new humans
if they have nothing to go back to?
Thankfully, SCP – 2000 has a contingency
for rebuilding both the infrastructure of
civilization as well as society itself.
The first generation of clones will have one
mission: Rebuild, and they have quite literally
all the resources in the world to do it.
In addition to having all the physical equipment
for buildings and agriculture, SCP – 2000
stores an immense amount of data.
Which is appropriate, considering the whole
facility is basically a huge backup drive
for life itself.
They have the entire internet backed up, as
well as the sum of all human memory, and a
wide cultural base with copies of thousands
of famous works of art, music, and literature.
They have all the scattered jigsaw pieces
of the time that came before, and it’s their
job to put the whole thing back together.
It’s expected that many of the first generation
of clones will die in this process, but that’s
fine.
With the BZHRs working at full capacity, anyone
can be replaced.
As the population increases and spreads across
the globe, rebuilding and recolonizing old
settlements, population growth will increase
exponentially.
Once society returns to some kind of normal,
decades after the activation of Procedure
Lazarus 01, it becomes the Foundation’s
task to restore the psychological and historical
status quo.
Administrators will falsify dendrochronological,
astronomical, and radiometric dating records
to make it seem as though history never paused.
They’ll then employ amnestic agent ENUI-5
en masse to erase and reconstruct the memories
of the entire human population, up until the
chosen time prior to the end of the world.
As far as any civilian knows, nothing ever
happened, history never stopped, and life
goes on.
It may seem comforting at first to know that
the ultimate contingency is out there.
Even if there’s a containment breach of
astronomical proportions, and the world as
we know it ends, there’s still a way out.
It means that there’s hope, even in the
bleakest situations, but of course, there
are always caveats.
After all, if a deal seems too good to be
true, it’s safe to assume it probably is.
Whether any of this works is dependent on
two factors: The first is that no anomalies
or human insurgents infiltrate the SCP – 2000
facility and destroy the equipment within.
It’s for this reason that discussion of
the facility is so restrictive – if ever
a powerful reality-warper discovered and gained
access to the facility, we would lose our
lifeboat.
The second factor is the overall integrity
of the machines.
After all, without proper maintenance, it’s
not hard for the technology to malfunction,
often to truly horrifying results.
The failure of some SRA and XACTS components
is believed to have caused erroneous BZHR
activity, resulting in the production of ten
million humanoid entities with internal biology
wildly inconsistent with humanity.
These beings remained unconscious for five
weeks before dying.
In the event of an XK class end of the world
scenario, well-maintained machines can reproduce
the human race.
But all it’d take is one little malfunction
to release ten million mutants who are effectively
dead on arrival.
Even with SCP – 2000 in our back pocket,
the fate of the world still lives on a knife’s
edge.
But in a way, that’s not even the most frightening
part of the existence of SCP – 2000.
Seeing as the machine can perfectly reproduce
reality without leaving a trace behind, it
raises the question: How many times has this
happened?
You may be surprised, but the Foundation can
confirm this occurring at least twice in recorded
history, but can you ever really be sure of
how many times your clone has crawled out
of the BZHR?
We received a disturbing clue to the reality
of the situation when human remains were discovered
on site at SCP – 2000.
All tests indicate the remains are between
450 and 700 years old, and have been matched
to the very-much-alive Dr. Alto Clef, who
has no knowledge of how these remains came
to be there.
The only other thing found with the remains
was a note, hermetically sealed in a plastic
document sleeve.
The note read:
“Why did we have to build this thing?
When did we do it?
How long have we been doing it?
Do we even know?!”
And the answer?
No, we don’t.
And for everyone’s piece of mind, it’s
probably best to just forget about it.
If you can…
Now go check out “SCP – 096 The Shy Guy”
and “SCP – 087 The Stairwell” for more
strange and surprising stories from the SCP
Foundation.